[Musique]
troisième numéro du club de la presse
pour cette saison merci de nous
rejoindre sur tv 78 radio sensations à
mes côtés pour revenir sur l'actualité
et des yvelines ce mois-ci alexandre
marqué pour toutes les nouvelles et 7,8
actus.fr et nicolas kirillovitch pour
radio sensations 98.4 bonjour à vous
deux bonjour au cours de l'émission on
our adina n'y de marmites fm nous
rejoindra également et puis vous l'avez
aperçu deux invités vont nous
accompagner pendant ces premières
minutes pendant cette première partie
d'émission joséphine coleman ce berger
la mère de plaisir et sonia breux la
maire de saint cyr l'école
bonjour à vous deux bonjour et merci de
participer à ce club de la presse au
programme aujourd'hui le gouvernement a
assuré que 1% des 100 milliards d'euros
prévus par le plan de relance serait
destiné aux quartiers défavorisés
après l'appel d'une centaine d'élus pour
autant ces derniers sont-ils rassurer
les petits commerces ouvrent leurs
portes à nouveau mais vont ils sauver
leur noël quelques éléments de réponse à
suivre et nous évoquons aussi la
situation et des restaurateurs toujours
dans la tente
et puis qui sont les yvelinoises et les
yvelinois du mois politiques sportifs
entrepreneurs leurs noms à la fin de
l'émission quelques sujets également qui
feront la une de l'actualité et dans les
yvelines et dans les prochains jours
nous en parlerons également il sera
question entre autres de la 5g et puis
de l'ancien préfet des yvelines
aujourd'hui devant la justice
elle le 14 novembre dernier près de 150
maires de france signait une tribune à
destination du gouvernement ces élus
demandaient avec 1 % du plan de relance
soit dirigé vers les quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
elle soit la somme d'un milliard d'euros
joséphine coleman ce berger sonia breux
vous faites partie de ces élus
signataires jean castex a répondu
favorablement il semble à cette demande
est ce que déjà ça vous semble
satisfaisant dans un premier temps va
commencer avec vous ou joséphine comme
anne berger puis saunière bros ensuite
écouté j'ai entendu la proposition
satisfaisant on verra bien moi je j'ai
besoin d'action j'ai besoin de deux
choses concrètes je dis pas que j'ai pas
confiance mais en tout cas aujourd'hui
nous on a fait toute une liste de
propositions et des attentes qui sont
concrètes puisqu'on est au plus proche
de la population
on a quand même l'habitude d'être sur le
terrain si un petit peu ce qui nous pose
problème avec le gouvernement actuel
c'est que on est très très loin d'eux
ait eu très très loin de nous donc à
partir de ce moment là oui pourquoi pas
on a entendu qu'il pouvait y avoir ce
rapprochement avec nous et dont on
attend des actes maintenant
sonia bros je crois qu on se rejoint
dans l'analyse on est ravi d'avoir
entendu que monsieur le premier ministre
s'engager sur ce qu'est un bourg sans
m'attendre le voir écrit dans la loi des
finances
voilà question assez pragmatique quand
c'est écrit c'est mieux et on sera très
attentif aussi est ce que en effet les
quartiers néant politique de la ville
soit bénéficiaire mais aussi tous les
autres tous ceux qui vont basculer
la situation dans ma commune sur saint
cyr l'école par exemple nous nous étions
quartiers prioritaires jusqu'à la
dernière réforme ne sommes plus nous
avons 37 % de logements sociaux avec un
on va dire à peu près on est à peu près
à 2% au-dessus de la moyenne nationale
dans les villes de même strate de
personnes 2 % en dessous pardon les
déficients d'être socialement bien qu'en
fait chez nous il y avait des
travailleurs pauvres et ses travailleurs
pauvres ce que sont les premiers touchés
par la crise s'estompe poussé d'emplois
précaires qui ont basculé et qui
aujourd'hui écoutés tombe dans une
situation fort compliqué donc voilà on
sera très très attentif à ce que ces
personnes ne soient pas oubliées voilà
l'exemple vous n'hésitez pas à
intervenir également si vous le
souhaitez concrètement cet argent
pourrait aller vous dans vos différents
quartiers par exemple un plaisir ou à
saint cyr l'école en ce qui concerne
plaisir mais avec nous on a un quartier
politique de la ville et accompagné
aujourd'hui par l'anru donc il ya
beaucoup de démarches qui sont en cours
les reconstructions des démolitions
reconstructions au niveau de la sécurité
il ya un vrai travail à mettre en place
on a on a tout eu toute une série
d'actions bien sûr au sein de notre
collectivité par le biais de la police
massifs nationaux municipal pardon et
surtout avec nos médiateurs qui sont
complètement pris en charge par la
collectivité
donc on a besoin de ces appuis là qui
sont des appuis de médiation des appuis
d'anticipation avant même de régler les
problèmes de sécurité il faut anticiper
donc on a un vrai besoin
d'accompagnement à ce niveau là on a un
besoin d'accompagnement aussi par
rapport à tout ce qui est structure
équipements culturels la culture et le
sport sont des sons des choses
indispensables aujourd'hui et puis
l'emploi alors plaisir
non on a on a peu de chômage / plaisir
certes mais dans le quartier de la
politique de la vie je rejoins ma ma
collègue sonia bros qui effectivement
dit que et on le constate qu une
paupérisation se met en place dans ces
quartiers là et pas uniquement dans ces
quartiers là donc il va y avoir dans
tous les domaines dans tous les secteurs
on a été très clair sur notre courrier
d'un besoin d'accompagnement
multidisciplinaire
très large par rapport à ceux à qui on
nous on est prêts il suffit qu'on vienne
de concerter et on sera très bien
comment utiliser cet argent sajoo
garantie sonia breux pour répondre aussi
à la question d'alexandre sur l'emploi
l'utilisation de cet argent est ensuite
alors je rejoins ma collègue
en effet je vous rassure on est prêts on
sait quoi faire
il ya énormément de travail sur la
prévention de la délinquance
saint cyr a été obligé de labarde
abandonné par exemple le dispositif des
éducateurs de rue quantité d en place on
se demandait des fois quoi ça servait
maintenant qu'ils y sont plus je vous
rassure on sait exactement quel était
leur action accompagner ces jeunes vers
le retour à l'emploi vers pôle emploi
vers le retour à des formations à de la
qualification c'était primordial c'est
assurer les années futures et assurer
leur leur employabilité
honnêtement je pense que vraiment le
défi qui se qui se tend à nous sur les
prochains mois sur les proches des trois
prochaines années
c'est vraiment l'emploi des jeunes c'est
vraiment le retour à l'emploi des plus
précaires je crois que déjà si on
arrivait à être performant sur ce sur
cet axe là on serait en serait pas mal
et on est prêt en tous les cas les
lignes territoire nous sommes prêts
c'est ce qui ressortait du courrier de
cet appel du 14 novembre qui avait été
signé par les différents maires dont
donc vous deux qui est avec nous
aujourd'hui on sait aussi cette demande
de généralisation des sites et
éducatives augmentation des moyens pour
les associations dans la loi de finances
2021 150000 parcours emploi compétences
plutôt que 24000 également ou encore
l'implantation de recyclerie pour
booster l'économie circulaire là
quelques pistes qui avait été lancée
dans ce courrier nicolas également pour
radio sensations
oui puisque vous évoquiez tout toutes
les deux la paupérisation et le
nécessaire retour à l'emploi des plus
jeunes
est ce qu'une fois que les aides de
l'état notamment pour les entrepreneurs
pour les entreprises seront seront
terminés ce que et que la crise
économique qui a suivi immédiatement la
crise sanitaire se fera vraiment
ressentir et notamment dans les
quartiers les plus fragiles on le sait
est ce que vous craignez une des
tensions au sein de ces quartiers en
avez vu on avait vu tel que quelques
actualités à la fin du premier
confinement est ce que vous pensez que
dans trois ou quatre mois la situation
sociale pourrait exploser qu'on pourrait
avoir au peut-être pas une crise est une
crise des banlieues comme on l'avait eue
il ya une quinzaine d'années mais en
tout cas voilà ce type de ce type
d'événement qui pourrait se reproduire
quels sont les retours que vous avez
vous sur le terrain ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que la tension allait déjà la
cites une tension que l'on ressent mais
c'est une tension qui n'est pas
uniquement dans ces quartiers là elle et
elle est globale
on est tous tendus je pense que vous
l'êtes également on est dans une
situation très particulière
donc aujourd'hui on n'est pas sûr je
dirais une angoisse permanente mais
orange prépare à un retour de flamme je
dirai qui et qui ne sera que légitime
alors personne n'a de vraies
responsabilités puisque on est face à
une pandémie qu'on essaye justement de
gérer mais il est clair qu'il faut qu'on
se prépare à cela
donc aujourd'hui se préparer c'est être
proche de la population dans quelque
chose d'immédiat qui est bien sûr l'aide
solidaire que l'on mis en place je crois
que tous les maires aujourd'hui en cette
démarche là mais on est aussi dans une
proximité des coûte de présence de coups
de téléphone de savoir comment les
choses se passent pour pouvoir moduler
modérés tout cela pour éviter justement
qu'il y ait ce genre de crise et
d'explosions
je suis quelqu'un de très optimiste donc
je me dis qu'il n'ya pas de raison que
quand on va retrouver une certaine
liberté on va dire eh bien les choses se
passent plutôt bien il faut qu'on soit
là et il faut qu'on soit accompagnée
qu'on se serre les coudes les uns les
autres
les mots employés dans le courrier qui a
été signé par essence à quelque 150 élus
sont assez forts un sentiment de non
assistance à territoires en danger il y
à une détresse sociale et économique
également sonia breux sur le terrain
vous le ressentez évidemment
voyez par exemple c'est tout ce que dans
nos territoires on a des zones de trafic
et bien quand on n'a plus d'emploi il
s'avère qu'on se tourne vers d'autres
économies et aujourd'hui c'est pas un
sentiment c'est palpable
c'est quantifiable nous malheureusement
concrètement moi je on vient de passer
le relais je veux un peu plus d'un mois
du deuxième confinement mais moi j'ai
pas les forces de l'ordre sur mon
territoire nécessaire pour aller faire
ne serait ce que des contrôles dans ces
endroits là et je vois de plus en plus
de jeunes de plus en plus jeunes qui se
groupent au pied des des vols qui
augmente le trafic et je ne suis même
pas en capacité de répondre dans ces
halls d'immeuble ya ces jeunes mais il
ya aussi des gens qui habitent
il ya aussi des gens qui ont déterminé
cdd qui se sont pas poursuivis parce que
l'activité ne le permet pas je sais pas
ce qu'est ce qu'on parle d'ambiance
quand vous êtes chez vous et que
régulièrement vos lumières de halls sont
cassés veaux sont squattés que vous osez
plus prendre un tiers qu'il faudrait il
sortir et que c'est pas évident ça
correspond pas forcément au mode de vie
qu'on vous impose et qu'à côté de ça il
ya pas de réponse
il n'y a pas de réponse parce qu'il ya
pas de moyens je suis en train de dire
que la police fait pas son travail et je
suis en train de dire qu'il n'ya pas de
moyens c'est que nous des bondynois
saint cyr du commissariat de police de
plaisir nous avons fait nous
saint-cyr-l'ecole une demande expresse
au
au ministre de l'intérieur justement de
donner plus de moyens parce qu'on voit
bien que quand on les appelle bay et pas
les patrouilles sais c'est pas l'on veut
pas venir s'il n'y a pas les batroun et
ben ça c'est compliqué il s'était
compliqué d'expliquer à des gens qui
sont déjà dans une situation descendante
qu'on ne peut pas les accompagne et
qu'on n'est pas en capacité de trouver
des solutions
je suis moins optimiste que ma collègue
je suis désolé oui c'est bon on entend
aussi si vous souhaitez une fois de plus
alexandre pour 7 8 actions ou nicolas
intervenir n'hésitez pas j'aimerais si
oui nicolas allez-y oui puisqu'on
parlait à l'instant des moyens sonia
brou parler des moyens il ya un rapport
de la cour des comptes qui a été publiée
cette semaine sur les quartiers dits
prioritaires et visiblement ce que dit
la cour des comptes alors je ne reprends
pas ses mots pour moi mais c'est pas
forcément les moyens qui ne sont pas
suffisants c'est plutôt comment ils sont
utilisés dans ces quartiers et la cour
des comptes appelle parfois une à une
pluie plus important de décentralisation
et avoir à s est ce que ce serait pas
mieux que ce soit les villes qui soit en
charge de tous ces fonds de la politique
de la ville plutôt que si je ne dis pas
de bêtises mais à saint quentin en
yvelines c'est l'agglomération qui est
en charge de cette politique là est ce
qu'il faudrait pas encore plus
décentralisée de ce soit vous les maires
directement qu'ils aient les moyens
puisque vous connaissez bien votre
quartier vous connaissez bien les
problèmes dans chacun des quartiers
puisque les problèmes ne sont pas
toujours les mêmes mais ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cela vous avez complété
avant de vous laisser répondre sur
l'argent qui est débloquée aussi parce
qu'il ya de l'argent débloqué les
ministres et différents ministres
rappellent aussi par exemple elisabeth
bornes qui rappelle qu'il ait eu à 6,7
milliards d'euros déjà débloqués pour la
formation l'insertion des jeunes la
ministre déléguée au logement
de son côté évoque le programme de
renouvellement urbain qui est porté à 10
milliards d'euros donc de l'argent il y
en as qu'après derrière justement pour
revenir sur ce que disait nicolas faut
que vous ayez plus de clés en main pour
mieux l'utiliser peut-être si jamais il
était mal utilisé je pense que c'est
ce qu'on attend les uns et les autres
toute façon c'était criant dans notre
dans notre courrier
on a bien dit laissez nous gérer c'est
important comme disait sonia nous on est
dans les halls d'immeubles
on est sur le terrain on sait
pertinemment comment les choses se
passent
on rentre dans les appartements on voit
ce qui s'y passe on travaille en
relation étroite avec les bailleurs
on sait tout à fait la difficulté des
uns et des autres pour nous quand on
parle corlieu politique de la ville
quartiers en difficulté on parle pas
d'un amalgame
on parle de personnes d'individus on les
voit on les regarde je veux dire et
c'est avec eux qu'on fonctionne donc
c'est bien ce qu'on a réclamé dans ce
courrier je pense que sony allait
complètement d'accord parce que on l'a
signe ensemble pour dire mais on est
grand arrêtez de nous faire des procès
d'intention en disant vous donne de
l'argent ne savais pas quoi en faire
où on nous donne de l'argent c'est pas
où il passe c'est faux c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est que
cet argent certainement il tombe on sait
pas très bien où et comment nous on en a
pas vraiment la possibilité de du
déploiement dans les bonnes actions
laissez-nous faire la décentralisation
est quelque chose d'important
aujourd'hui les agglomérations font ce
qu'elles peuvent mais on se rend compte
que c'est encore une fois un éloignement
par rapport à ça donc il ya des
compétences certainement qu'ils doivent
être distribués aux collectivités et en
mer moi je le dis haut et fort et je
rejoins sonia mon côté optimiste et un
optimisme si on nous donne la capacité
de faire les choses pas si on continue
de fonctionner comme ça mais en tout cas
je peux vous dire que oui décentralisant
dono nous on est là faites nous
confiance on est là pour en prendre
plein la figure on est là pour
accompagner les gens franchement oui
franchement oui décentralisant et on est
là je te de de liberté pour agir après
alors moi j'irais même un peu plus loin
décentralisons donnant au maire qui
connaissent la population qui
connaissent les personnes les moyens
d'agir et nous faisons face à une
situation qui est complètement nouvelle
qui va entraîner des détresses
économique et social absolument
épouvantables ne nous bornons pas s'il
vous plaît à une groupe delhaize qui a
été de l'échevine alors que ces
problématiques l'année n'existait pas
inventons nous par rapport à une
situation nouvelle et et soyons
pragmatiques regardons sur le terrain
quelles sont les conséquences
où il ya besoin de mettre les moyens ne
nous ne restons pas figé sur des règles
qui ont été déterminés dans une
situation où le covan et des plats ou
l'emploi et des différents il fait et
pour ça y'a pas de secret c'est les
mères c'est eux qui sont au contact de
la population
moi je suis capable de vous dire point
par point dans ma ville où les impacts
seront les plus importants et je pense
que joséphine est dans le même cas dans
le même esprit avec ses ouailles cola si
vous souhaitez intervenir je me tourne
vers mais mes confrères puisque nous
arrivons à la fin de cette séquence
dernière question la suite est ce que au
sein de ce collectif de 150 élus ya déjà
d'autres actions qui sont qui sont
prévues dans les semaines ou les mois à
venir des actions je veux dire en
parallèle de sa vous savez on n'a pas
attendu eux de faire ce courrier on n'a
pas attendu que la réponse du premier
ministre arrive à nous on est en
permanence sur le territoire est en
permanence en train de faire des actions
on évoquait tout à l'heure des présents
cela sur des paniers solidaires parce
que avec les bailleurs on a mis ça en
place parce que la ville met ça en place
on a organisé des des jeux veut dire des
collectes de jouets parce qu'on sait que
ça va être compliqué cette année c'est
pas de la démagogie ainsi du concret on
est là et alors la lettre est une chose
qu'on a mis en place bien sûr on en
attend les résultats et les choses et
qui cassent et puis mais me dire nous on
est déjà en action depuis toujours
depuis le mois de mars elle gagna qui a
été présent au premier confinement c'est
bien non c'est bien les maires les
masques qui s'en est occupé qui a
distribué ses les maires soyons sûrs que
soyons très
vers là dessus donc oui on fait des
courriers on appelle au gouvernement
leur discours n'est là mais en attendant
on avance on n'est pas la racine en
juillet dans nos cerveaux pour rien
faire on est on est tous présents sur le
territoire allemand ses films comme the
verge et sonia breux merci à vous
d'avoir participé à ce club de la presse
d'avoir répondu aux collègues des mes
collègues et atv 78 pour les médias
locaux
je rappelle que donc vous faites partie
des signataires de ce courrier avec plus
de 150 élus de france pour demander plus
d aide pour les quartiers les plus en
difficulté en raison de cette crise
sanitaire et économique aujourd'hui
merci à vous deux nous allons parcourir
avec les musées de médias locaux les
autres sujets à la une
de retour sur le plateau de tv 78
toujours avec alexandre marqué pour
toutes les nouvelles et 7,8 actus.fr
nicolas kirillovitch pour radio
sensations et également nouradine agne
pour marmite fm bonjour nouradine dont
jean wilfrid bonjour également amical et
demi d'euros pour tv 78 en plateau dans
le reste de l'actualité était ce mois ci
les petits commerces vont ils sauver
leur noël libraire artisans réclamé la
possibilité d'ouvrir c'est maintenant
chose faite est trop tard avant de faire
un premier état des lieux écouter ce
micro-trottoir patrick jacques de
dixmude et allez vous demander si vous
alliez faire vos courses de fin d'année
chez vos commerçants locaux j'essaie de
faire du click and collect ou bien de
donner maintenant que magasins sont
ouverts d'aller dans les magasins mais
j'ai attendu que magasins rouvrent il
faut faire vivre les petits commerces
on en a besoin rachète jamais en ligne à
part si je fais faire des livraisons
mais pour le commerce sinon je préviens
j'ai bien sûr tous les petits
commerçants je suis primeur je pense que
les gens ont acheté plus en ligne
parce que comme on pouvait pas se
déplacer et beaucoup de commerces
avaient été fermés ce qui a changé c'est
qu'on a tout commandé par
ben en ligne puis on sais pas vous moi
c'est ça va arriver avant les 24
décembre
pour moi c'est un peu plus important
pour les commerces de proximité parce
qu'on sait que leur survie est lent
dépend donc je vais penser à eux aussi
pour ça bien sûr quitte à mettre un
petit peu plus cher s'il faut c'est
important pour moi pour faire travailler
les commerces qui sont à proximité de
chez moi
voilà pourquoi aller plus loin c'est
commercy donnée essentielle qui
maintenant sont ouverts ils n'auront que
peu de temps pour réaliser leur chiffre
d'affaires les uns les autres est ce que
vous avez rencontré des commerçants qui
sont inquiets en ce moment alexandre
peut-être ou est ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que l'année 2020 ce sera quoi
qu'il arrive une année catastrophique
pour les commerces en termes de chiffre
d'affaires
l'objectif pour tous maintenant c'est de
limiter la casse donc il ya une dame qui
parle notamment du click and collect ça
a permis évidemment de limiter un peu la
casse et de ne garder lien les clients
mais est-ce que ça suffira ça c'est une
autre question
il ya le premier week-end de réouverture
a été plutôt bon ce qui prouve que les
français ont par porter tous leurs
lâches inverse vers la vente en ligne
maintenant faut voir il leur reste trois
week-ends pour pour sauver la leur fait
quelquefois il ya des initiatives plus
ou moins originale qui peut voir le jour
des commerçants qui tente d'attirer les
clients de cette manière là vous allez
avoir recours aux commerces locaux
je vais faire un petit sondage parmi les
journalistes et qu'ils sont là une bonne
question
oui effectivement alors pour pour moi
c'était déjà le cas je privilégie en
général les les commerces locaux
mais comme disait alexandre c'est vrai
que bon je crois que vendredi là c'est
le black black friday le vendredi noir
c'est marrant quand on traduit en france
c'est plus inquiétant qu'autre chose
mais bon qui a été qu'ils étaient
décalés à au 4 décembre pour essayer de
add aussi des commerces et y compris les
commerces locaux mais je suis pas sûr
que ça profite vraiment beaucoup aux
commerces locaux j'ai l'impression que
le black friday profite quand même plus
au commerce en ligne
donc va falloir voir si les les
françaises et les français les fonds
réussir en tout cas changer un petit peu
leurs habitudes pour vraiment se diriger
vers vers les commerces locaux
même si c'est bien le cas et un
attachement fort comme aux commerces
locaux mais bon contre les grands
commerces en ligne voilà est-ce que la
concurrence est vraiment est vraiment
loyal
voilà ça c'est la question qu'on peut se
poser michael sur ce que vient de dire
nouradine j'ai appelé notamment à
versailles pour pour caler des sujets à
versailles pour le 'black friday'
justement et aucun commerce local fait
le black friday parce qu'ils auraient
perdu entre 30 et 60 % de chiffre
d'affaires sur l'année
du coup ils ne veulent pas absolument
pas faire de rab et du coup sûr ces
trois jours ils estiment que le prix est
juste dans un commerce local le prix
serait plus juste peut-être que dans la
grande distribution et du coup il n'y
aura pas de black friday à versailles
notamment dans les commerces de
proximité si on peut préciser aussi que
les la période des soldes a été décalé
ça a été annoncé aussi ce vendredi matin
du côté des libraires aussi nicolas
kirilow vite pour radio sensations vous
avez fait un petit point aussi il ya
quelques quelques jours avec les
libraires c'est ça tout à fait puisque
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que les
locaux de la radio se trouve à elancourt
place du commerce juste à côté du pavé
dans la mare donc on en a profité pour
pour faire l'interview du directeur du
pavé dans la mare michel fourré long là
on l'a reçu en plateau pour pour lui
demander voilà comment s'était passé ses
premiers jours depuis le déconfinement
et des petits commerces et puis quelles
sont les perspectives pour noël vous
allez voir il va nous parler
d'inquiétude aussi au moment où la foule
va pas être plus importante dans c'est
dans ces locaux etc on peut l'écouter je
pense on a la chance d'avoir une surface
importante quand même donc
on a une capacité d'accueil de 35
personnes à ce jour on peut dire que ça
circule dans les jours à venir
plus on va se rapprocher de la date de
noël et puis ça va devenir compliqué en
effet
on sent bien que il va falloir qu'ils
aient une fille de la tente à
l'extérieur malheureusement et c'est
parce que noël c'est une grosse période
est ce que vous avez période voilà
est-ce que vous avez pas peur justement
que finalement les gens fuient un petit
peu mais que ce soit bas les librairies
ou même les autres petits commerces pour
aller finalement sur internet car oui et
non je pense que les deux sont possibles
mais on
on a un tel soutien quand même de notre
de notre clientèle que je pense
ils vont anticiper cet attachement
malgré tout aussi les uns et des autres
à leur petit commerce et les libraires
sont assez emblématique là dessus alors
certains des commerces sont ouverts
d'autres toujours pas ils vont devoir
attendre fin décembre voire même en
encore en janvier on peut penser aux
restaurateurs
là aussi je vais vous laisser encore la
parole nicolas vous aviez fait le point
avec le secteur hôtelier
oui avec le représentant de de l'umih
donc le syndicat qui représente
l'ensemble des professionnels du secteur
on les avait reçus dans une émission
spéciale juste avant l'allocution du
président de la république mardi dernier
on savait déjà même avant l'allocution
que pour eux il n'y aurait pas de
perspectives à court terme de
réouverture on l'avait interrogé on l'a
interrogé notamment précisément sur une
étude que l'umih avait réalisé et qui a
indiqué que près des deux tiers en fin
de tiers selon eux des restaurateurs
risque la fermeture d'ici là la fin du
confinement une fois que cette crise
sera vraiment passé
on lui a demandé qu'en était-il vraiment
de ces chiffres selon une étude de
lumière la crise du couronne à virus
pourrait entraîner la fermeture de deux
établissements sur trois dans le secteur
de l'hôtellerie restauration 2 sur 3
c'est quand même impressionnant est ce
que à la fin de cette crise 66 % des
restaurants vont fermer
vraiment alors au moins 50% et je
voudrais quand même vous attirez attirer
votre attention sur le fait que nous
n'avons pas l'étranger actuellement et
que même les hôtels ont complètement
fermé j'ai des petits hôtels avec une
quinzaine de chambres en tant
qu'adhérent qui ont complètement fermée
jeter l'épongé parce que la saison a été
très mauvaise que les cons les comptes
on est sur des trésoreries qui sont à
flux tendu on n'est même pas capable
2 comment dire de les aider correctement
et on se retrouve avec oui on aura au
moins au moins 50% de fermeture certains
restaurateurs pendant ces périodes
difficiles ont aussi fait le choix de la
vente à emporter avec des fortunes
diverses aussi en fonction de la
position géographique principalement des
différents établissements
prenons un exemple concret aussi
nouradine pour radio marmite
vous avez rencontré un restaurateur
installé sur trappe oui effectivement il
aa montini wilfried il est pas la trappe
damien donc le resto cocorico mais
effectivement c'est il fait partie de
ces nombreux restaurateurs qui ont bas
qui ont investi en la personne de
l'heure de leur argent pour pour pour
monter un commerce et qui se voient dans
la difficulté notamment avec la noce qui
repoussait jusqu'au 20 janvier
l'ouverture des restaurants et on va
écouter un petit un petit bout de son
témoignage où réside justement juste au
lendemain de l annonce du président à
vrai dire on l'attendait en traitant
d'un petit peu aller à lille annonce que
les plus récentes nous annoncer des
blacks on serait sans doute permets moi
de défendre on fait pas forcément une
surprise
une mauvaise nouvelle oui mais pas il
n'est pas une surprise depuis l annonce
du second confinement et donc les
fermetures des restaurants vous êtes
elle a en fait revenir puisque vous
l'aviez déjà commencé à la vente à
emporter et la livraison est ce que ça
marche parce que c'est suffisant pour
faire survivre si je puis dire le
restaurant non non non non c'est pas
suffisant le but vraiment de la vente à
emporter par deux du moins de mon côté
c'est aujourd'hui de deux gardiens un
lien avec les clients ne pas permet de
et de continuer à le battre maintenant
le chiffre d'affaires que ça représente
est vraiment minime on avait déjà
quelques au premier confinement donc on
fait aujourd'hui sur quels services la
vente en porte s est rentable donc moi
aujourd'hui j'ai choisi d'ouvrir ce
n'est uniquement quatre jours et quatre
soirs plus précisément donc du mercredi
soir aux femmes d'histoire qui sont les
ferias où on a du mois de plus de
commander ce qui nous permettent de
rentabiliser un maximum d'ouverture
il faut quand même des salariés et puis
et puis un ensemble de mises en place
pour pour réaliser les faire vivre
voilà pour cet exemple de ce
restaurateur inciter à
montigny-le-bretonneux donc je pense que
je disais tout à l'heure
fortunes diverses pour les restaurateurs
là aussi du côté des nouvelles 7,8 actu
vous en avez rencontré quelques-uns
aussi sur le terrain qui sont en
difficulté aujourd'hui ou qui arrivent
malgré tout à survivre oui moi je
raconterai le responsable du du resto
des templiers à à elancourt un resto
gastronomique et lui en l'occurrence par
exemple lui il peut pas faire de vente à
emporter parce que avec un ticket moyen
à 55 euros
c'est inné envisageable du fait des
charges trop importante
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que les les
restaurants et ce sont les grands
perdants de ce deuxième confinement
parce qu en tout ils me disaient qu'ils
seront restés fermés +26 jamais réouvre
le 20 janvier ils sont restés fermés
plus de six mois dans l'année sur
l'année cumulé était moi ou ils ont été
ouverts ça a été les mois d'été qui sont
les mois les moins importants pour eux
et surtout va être fermé par an en
novembre décembre janvier
or et réalise 30% le marché chiffre
d'affaires annuel donc il est d'avoir
détruit des trop des gros dégâts pour
ceux qui n'ont pas fait une trésorerie
de compagnie une trésorerie de côté
quand beaucoup de mal à s'en remettre
dans le bain restaurateurs et les salles
de sport également l âge ne tourne vers
michael parce que non pas c'est un
adepte des salles des sports comme
le sait bien sûr mais aussi parce qu'il
s'occupe du secteur des sports pour télé
78 voilà plus du secteur des sports que
du sport en lui-même
michael du côté des salles de sport
aussi à une vraie inquiétude vraie
inquiétude du côté des salles de sport
elle ne devrait pas rouvrir avant fin
janvier également mais par contre on
peut quand même faire du sport je sais
c'est un petit peu étonnant on peut
faire du sport sur ordonnance notamment
je suis allé il ya il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça dans la salle des
machines à guyancourt dans cette salle
là il y avait environ je sais pas entre
30 et 50 personnes qui faisait du sport
ce jour là bien sûr je me suis
questionnée je me suis demandé pourquoi
il y avait autant de personnes dans
cette salle de sport mais expliqué que
c'était sur ordonnance donc si on a mal
au dos par exemple si on a envie de se
changer les idées on va dire avec le
télétravail
on peut faire du sport si le médecin a
recommandé le recommande un des exemples
pour essayer de survivre un peu aussi
pour ces salles et ce secteur économique
et aussi qui en a besoin
je propose qu'on laisse de côté cette
thématique à présent pour poursuivre ce
club de la presse nous allons parler des
personnalités du mois les journalistes
et des médias locaux des yvelines vont
nous livrer leur choix pour ce mois ci
notre rubrique personnalité du mois à
présent connus ou dans l'ombre ils ou
elles ont pour point commun d'avoir fait
l'actualité ces dernières semaines dans
les yvelines on va commencer avec vos
nicolas pour radio sensations qui avez
vous retenu il est plutôt question pour
vous de saluer le travail des
associations justement sur le terrain
oui tout à fait parce que on parle
souvent de cette crise et les
difficultés pour chacun d'entre nous à y
faire face et on a peut-être tendance
parfois à oublier que c'est encore plus
dur quand on est déjà de base dans la
difficulté économique social et voilà je
tenais à saluer la radio sensations la
réaction de toutes ces associations qui
travaillent il ya la croix rouge parmi
les plus importantes ya la croix rouge
les restos du coeur qui on le sait ont
lancé leur campagne d'hiver il ya peu de
temps
et puis il ya aussi la protection civile
nous on a reçu lors de l'émission
spéciale dont je vous parlais juste
avant il y à il ya une semaine on a reçu
le responsable de la communication de la
fédération nationale de la protection
civile qui nous parlait de ses actions
du terrain qui est forcément développées
ces dernières semaines puisqu'il n'était
plus en charge des événements sportifs
notamment qui sont qui sont à l'arrêt
tout le monde le sait et donc qu'ils
avaient réorienté une nombreuse de leur
action vers les plus précaires et les
plus fragiles la protection civile a
réenclenché sa plateforme d'appels qui
s'appelle solidarité donc c'est une
plateforme où tout le monde peut se
porter volontaire appelant volontaires
est en fait vous avez une connexion
internet qui vous donne le contact de
personnes a appelé qui sont seuls
fragile et vulnérable
aussi pour faire du lien social tout
simplement parlé un petit peu du la
pluie du beau temps de caisse qu'elle
fonde leur quotidien casser la routine
et puis ça peut détecter des situations
très difficiles des plateaux repas qui
sont plus libres et des infirmières qui
sont peuvent plus venir parce qu'elles
sont peu vide ou des choses comme ça et
nous on va pouvoir enclencher derrière
des actions pour corriger et éviter
baky des drames qui se produisent non à
digne de votre côté pour marmite ce
n'est pas une personnalité des
personnalités une famille oui tout à
fait on peut dire que c'est l'un des
héritiers de la de quatre filles du
docteur march
alors c'est pas un docteur et le papa ni
la maman mais la famille salle ses seins
un cri un garçon et ils ont décidé de
lancer au début du mois de septembre
d'un service de traiteur et c'est vrai
que c'était un voilage s'est découvert
alors la plupart vivent à saint quentin
en yvelines
il ya une personne qui vit un petit peu
plus long mais voilà donc cette histoire
de famille se trouvait alors il
s'appelle sally's gourmandise et voilà
ils se sont retroussé les manches
pendant pendant le confinement décidé de
créer des choses d'occuper des bas
surtout autour de la pâtisserie et puis
deux des petits mets salés sur les l'eau
à la bouche vous voyez où les frais d'un
quand j'en parle et voilà du coup
c'était pour vraiment un petit coup de
coeur et
mettre en avant si celles et ceux qui
ont décidé malgré le confinement pas de
lancer des choses et puis et puis ça
marche le bouche à oreille commence à
bien marcher
et puis voilà c'était un petit clin
d'oeil pour cette entreprise familiale
je vous laisse redonner le même c'est
donc sa liste gourmandise et sur 28 les
femmes vous pourrez retrouver dès la
semaine prochaine des interviews de
fatima sall fatima qu'on appelle aussi
douillet qui est une des co fondatrice
de sa liste gourmandise on parle de
sport presse de la nourriture aux sports
depuis tout à l'heure on passe aux
sports ça peut tout et c'est plutôt bien
pensée complémentaires c'est un sportif
yvelinois justement qui fait parler de
lui ce mois-ci minuit tout à fait
wilfried je vais vous parler de louis
burton skipper est actuellement 2e sur
le vendée globe 2020 ce qui n'est pas
rien il vient de passer le cap de bonne
espérance pour moi le burton est
vraiment une personnalité marquante du
département le navigateur a grandi à la
celle les bordes à côté de rambouillet
il passe également beaucoup de temps à
maurepas dans sa jeunesse en parallèle
il pratiquait la voile en bretagne avec
sa famille aujourd'hui il est à 35 ans
l'un des meilleurs skippers de la flotte
avec bureau vallée il a participé à
toutes les grandes courses au large de
participation à la route du rhum 5
participation à la transat jacques vabre
et surtout le vendée globe à trois
reprises la première fois l'expérience a
tourné court il avait percuté un
chalutier
après quelques jours de course en 2016
il avait cette fois-ci valider une très
belle septième place son palmarès n'est
pas encore flamboyant mais son nouveau
bateau bureau vallée 2 pour lui permet
de terminer sur le podium mais attention
un vendée globe c'est long et les
conditions climatiques peuvent être
extrêmes comme l'attesté cette vidéo
non
hélas
m
hu
français avec le sourire et avec
tellement de philosophie petit peu peur
c'est sa meilleure position sur ces cinq
meilleures positions toute sa carrière
pour l'instant il est deuxième
actuellement alors une tempête qui n'a
pas comment je disais que c'était un
trait c'est un drôle de confinement là
pour le coup oui il a choisi d'être
confirmée confinés dans la tempête on y
est de l'océan alors une tempête en tout
cas qu'il n'a pas empêché d'être
aujourd'hui à la deuxième place juste
derrière charlie dalin le médiateur a
passé le cap de bonne espérance au sud
de l'afrique
à bord de son imoca bureau vallée de
effet cap sur l'australie louis burton
c'est également quelqu'un de classe un
gentleman en témoigne cette vidéo
enregistrée cette semaine
il revient notamment sur le sauvetage de
kevin escoffier par jean le cam et
ki-moon escoffier qui est le cousin par
alliance de louis burton on écoute sa
réaction
avec très très peur
une angoisse au but valeurs d'humanisme
toi
même bateau c'était au tour s'était pas
dû être l'enfer
[Musique]
dire que j'ai beaucoup pensé à vous un
grand bravo bravo jean la classe kevin
l'assuré le comme d'habitude voilà c'est
cool ça c'est une histoire qui se
termine bien
quand
rendent vite retrouvé détient
c'est dommage je fais tu sois toujours
là
les cats chats au on a hâte en tout cas
de savoir si louis burton va finir
deuxième ou si tout simplement il va
finir ce vendée globe parce que c'est ce
n'est pas simple et si vous en êtes où
vous du vendée globe le vendée globe je
suis 200 millièmes sur virtual regatta
mais je ne perds pas espoir
je ne sais pas comment ça se passe dans
vos rédactions les uns et les autres sur
radio sensations marmite ou 7,8 actu
mais la compétition virtuelle au sein de
la rédaction atv 78 on peut vous invitez
a également souhaité les rejoindre on
dit une autre personne n'est pas le
temps pour ça c'est ça il ya une autre
il ya une autre actualité un autre
personnage sur lequel nous souhaitions
revenir et vous plus particulièrement
aussi alexandre c'est votre personnalité
du mois de personnalités politiques
aussi parce qu'il a alors s'il n'était
plus en activité depuis quelques années
déjà il a fortement marqué le le
département et saint quentin en yvelines
oui oui une fois n'est pas coutume je
voulais parler d'un homme politique
c'était pire certains cours que j'ai
connu à l'époque où il était maire un
host est une grande figure historique de
la verrière et de saint quentin en
yvelines
il avait été maire pcf de 1983 à 2012 de
la ville avant de passer la main à alain
ayache pour des raisons de santé durant
29 ans il a il a transformé sa ville
avec la rue l'habitation des deux cités
hlm la création là que la rénovation de
la mairie la création de la médiathèque
aimé-césaire il s'est battu aussi
pendant des années pour le prolongement
de la halle à 12 avec eux le maire de
coignières l'époque henri pailleux en
vingt et un et au delà de ça humainement
c'était un vrai personnage à très grande
taille très très cultivé qualité
d'ailleurs vice président de
l'agglomération 50 ans gulli en charge
de la culture
et puis ceux qui l'ont connu je sais pas
si vous avez déjà couvert des portages
avec lui à l'époque mais c'était à ses
discours c'était toujours quelque chose
que c'était un discours de 2,3 heures
bingo fidel castro c'est ce que j'allais
dire effectivement pour rebondir à ça
parce que c'est ce qui me vient aussi en
tête et pour pour bon pour justement
tout dire comme étant arrivé ici en 2000
2002 au sein de la rédaction tv 78 l'une
des premières communes que j'ai eu à
suivre était celle de la vère
r j'ai vite compris pourquoi on mettait
le petit nouveau sur la commune de la
verrière
c'est un bizutage que de suivre les
conseils municipaux les discours du
nouvel an de fin d'année de voeux du
maire percer l'un court qui durait de
nombreuses heures à lui même à la fin et
s'en fiche un essai et s'en fiche a
illeurs il est lui-même c'était une
blague
et donc il fait partie de cette
génération de mer de 55 minutes qu'ont
participé au développement de
l'agglomération comme rolando ça induit
en cours nicolas à bout à montigny ou
qui m'a land art qui font partie de ces
figures de cette agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
nous passons à notre dernière séquence
pour ce club de la presse bientôt à la
une
comme chaque mois nous nous penchons à
présent sur les sujets qui seront
bientôt à la une des différents médias
locaux du département alexandre on reste
avec vous pour 7,8 actus.fr les
nouvelles il sera question d'un sujet
assez inquiétant pour le coup
la 5g le développement de la 5g et ce
qui s'est passé du côté date aussi à une
enquête qui a été est diffusée sur chez
nos confrères de france télévisions et
qui suscite pas mal de remous
oui c'est un sujet qu'a créé beaucoup
d'inquiétude parce que donc je dois
complètement dans la quête a fait un
reportage à chez atos donc l'ex société
lex bull aux clayes-sous-bois en entrant
qui avait eu sept cas de cancer du
cerveau sera de la société et une
dizaine de cas de cancers également au
tour sur le bassin de vie autour d'eux
des clayes-sous-bois villepreux et les
plaisirs et long du coup ça crée
l'inquiétude chez les habitants et chez
les élus donc le sujet s'est invitée au
conseil municipal des clayes-sous-bois
ou nicholas hughes conseiller municipal
d'opposition de gauche a demandé la mise
en place d'une d'une enquête sanitaire
de mesures sanitaires ont demandé que
l'ensemble de la ville soient étudiées
concernant l'émission d'ondés
électromagnétiques et du coup la
polémique aussi c'est a touché la ville
voisine de plaisir où l'opposition en a
fait de même et aussi les représentants
de parents d'élèves de l'école marcel
jantes et aussi au nom du principe de
précaution ont demandé à ce que une
enquête soit faite ce qu'ils ont dit ils
ont des antennes relais qui sont à moins
de 50 50 mètres de l'école et donc du
coup ils sont très inquiet de la
situation et ils ont une chemise
aimerait que les antennes soient retirés
audio moins éloignées et que ça fasse un
peu comme je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez en 2003 y avait eu ce cas qui a
fait jurisprudence en combat et beaucoup
parlé c'était l'antenne relais qui était
au dessus de l'école est visée à saint
cyr l'école et sous la pression
médiatique les antennes orange et sfr
avaient fini par être démontée il ya
effectivement des cas également de
concert qui a touché des enfants aussi
sur cette école pour ça qu'il y avait
cette affaire à cette époque donc sujets
reportage à suivre bientôt dans vos
colonnes
j'en profite pour montrer les unes des
nouvelles éditions versailles édition
rambouillet de cette semaine il est bien
sûr question des commerçants des enjeux
de cette période réduite autour de noël
sur le plan des affaires nous en avons
parlé déjà tout à l'heure dans cette
émission le 3 décembre
c'était la journée internationale des
personnes en situation de handicap
nouradine c'est une semaine complète que
vous allez y consacrer sur votre antenne
oui effectivement wilfried on va essayer
de donner la parole à voile à plusieurs
associations saint-quentinoise bas vous
vous les connaissez 12 ou moins il y
aura notamment vivre debout par exemple
qui est basé raillé dans le court et
voilà pour essayer de les faire
témoigner notamment sur la façon dont
ils ont vécu le confinement les de
confinement qui a été très compliqué
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap
et puis voir les perspectives aussi pour
pour les semaines les mois à venir
et puis un tout autre sujet qui sera
abordé sur tv 60,18 cette fois ci dans
les prochains jours le passage devant la
justice de l'ancien préfet serge l'avant
poste de 2015 à 2018 il est soupçonné
durant cette période de détournement de
fonds publics de réalisation de faux
documents tout cela pour une affaire de
coeur avec sa maîtresse audience fixée
le 7 décembre au palais de justice de
versailles audience qui devrait être
rapide puisqu'il a plaidé en tout cas
coupable sur certains des certains des
aspects du dossier voilà il faudra
suivre ce sujet sur notre antenne et
puis j'imagine aussi chez nos confrères
je profite de la présence de michael
pour tv 78 qui s'occupe du sport pour
vous demander un petit mot des sujets
importants dossiers que vous avez traité
dans les prochains jours en vendée globe
forcément sur le sport vendée globe pour
le pour le sport vous par le sport tout
ce qu'il fait pas que d'user du secteur
square dont les acteurs soit on va
sûrement parler notamment de la reprise
dans certains clubs
du sport sans contact pour l'instant
mais dans les prochaines semaines il y
aura il y aura du contact on va parler
également je fais un portrait / manager
dali qui est une golfeuse
professionnelle qui vient de terminer sa
saison et qui s'entraîne au golf de la
boulie je vais également avoir une
interview avec antoine ghibaudo qui
s'entraînent à feucherolles c'est du
tennis cette fois ci la participer à
roland garros chez les juniors et c'est
un grand espoir du tennis mondial même
voilà il à hilla il a pour l'instant 15
ans il mesure 1 mètre 80 donc une future
pépite également ce sera à suivre dans
le journal au quotidien 18h du lundi au
vendredi sur tv 78 également deux ans si
on parlait sport ça c'est tous les 15
jours le mercredi pour la première
diffusion
et puis à partir du mois de janvier
retour progressif du 7-8 sport rendez
vous hebdomadaire le lundi pour
l'instant suspendu forcément en raison
de la suspension des différents
championnats et dans les startings voilà
tout cas on est prêt à repartir
nouradine volet des rameaux oui je vous
ai entendu je ne sais pas avec une
petite touche d'ironie cher wilfried
enfin nom de serge m'en rends dire tout
ça pour toutes les histoires jadis si
j'ai dit tout ça c'est vrai vous êtes un
grand amoureux certainement wilfried
vous savez ce qu'on peut faire par amour
comme betis mme alheureusement donc
voila vous voulez nous a choqués
prochains jours a dit à un petit
détournement de fonds n'ont pas marmite
vous savez détourné les fonds d'une
marmite
on n'y a rien à craindre c'est vrai oui
on sait le travail que vous devez faire
au quotidien après que c'est une
structure associative aussi avec des
moyens forcément qu'ils sont limités
pour pour suivre l'actualité du bassin à
nicolas kirillovitch radio sensations
vous allez recevoir le président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines prochainement
oui on va le recevoir dès ce dimanche
pour notre émission hebdomadaire l'hebdo
politique jean michel fourgous ce
présent de l'agglomération et maire
d'elancourt est évidemment avec lui on
va on va parler de cette crise qui
impacte
les finances sont sais que c'est un
grand défenseur de l'attractivité
économique on va on va essayer de savoir
avec lui jusqu'à jusqu'à peut-être quel
point ce ce jusqu'à quel point ce
confinement a impacté de l'attractivité
économique de l'agglomération et il va
notamment nous donner un chiffre
c'est que pour l'instant il estime que
20 millions d'euros c'est le coût de la
crise pour l'agglomération pour les
finances de l'agglomération aujourd'hui
est que plus ça va durer plus plus plus
le coût va augmenter il faudra voir
ensuite l'impact que cela peut avoir sur
les la politique qui est menée sur les
secteurs sur des réductions
éventuellement aussi budgétaire il ya
beaucoup d'enjeux derrière tout ça et ça
sera forcément et malheureusement ce qui
fera l'actualité sur 2021 et c'est
justin 19 heures j'ai pas précisé mais
du coup la diffusion c'est dimanche à 19
heures sur radio sensations et ce
dimanche à 19h et puis sur la chaîne
youtube aussi de radio sensations vous
pouvez retrouver non seulement cette
intervention là et puis toutes les
autres dont nous avons diffusé des
extraits au cours du club de la presse
merci nicolas merci alexandre aussi pour
le 7-8 actus.fr et les nouvelles merci
nouradine d'avoir participé également
pour marmite
merci à michael pour tv 78 et puis merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis aussi bien
sur tv 78 que sur ado sensations on se
retrouve en janvier d'ici là à passer de
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année sans oublier
de vous protéger de protéger les autres
aussi c'est important
à bientôt
[Musique]